(rock music)
- The Jeselnik & Rosenthal Vanity Project.
- [Both] JRVP.
- [Erika] Junior vice president.
- We're gonna start the news with
my favorite story to
come across the NFL wires
in a long time, and that
was Bills cornerback
Vontae Davis deciding
to retire at halftime.
He pulled himself out of the game;
just went up to the coaches.
He started the game.
Played 29 snaps in the first half.
And according to Bills
coach Sean McDermott,
just told them he was done,
put on his street clothes, got in his car,
and left the stadium right away.
He said he meant no disrespect
to his coaches and teammates.
He just thought it was time
to end his career at halftime.
- How do you feel about that?
I saw a lot of players saying
it was the most disrespectful
thing they've ever seen.
How did you,
how do sports journalists feel about it?
Are they kind of laughing at it?
Or are they upset with him?
They think it's a weak move.
- It's one of those
stories that's annoying
'cause everyone has the exact same take,
which is just, how could he do that?
That's the worst thing
that you could possibly do.
It's so disrespectful to your teammates.
And I understand that.
But I kind of almost just felt bad,
'cause to be in the mental
space that he had to be in
to quit at halftime,
probably was not a fun thing.
There's a reason why no
one quits during a game.
- Sure.
- That's a pretty almost
difficult thing to do,
to have to just say,
"Bye, see ya."
- Absolutely.
My only problem with it,
I mean, I've seen all these takes of like,
it's disrespectful, it's awful.
You gotta be with your team, whatever.
The team doesn't care about the player.
And if he had handled it
differently, been like,
"Coach, I'm hurt."
And then after the game done it,
no one would have cared.
- Or just half-assed the
second half of the game,
which plenty of people would have done.
- Yeah.
My only problem is that he
changed into street clothes
before he left.
I think you want to walk
out of there full uniform
with the pads, 'cause they're
not gonna get 'em back.
They're not gonna send
somebody to your house.
And again, my dream would
be to quit and just leave
in the middle of a show.
- Anthony?
Anthony?
- I'm still here.
See, that was me wanting to show you
what a terrible actor Greg is.
Because Greg could not pull that off.
It'd be like, you would think like,
oh, is Anthony still there?
And then as soon as Greg opens his mouth,
like let's do it with you.
Tell me you want to
quit the show.
- It has always been my dream
to quit at the halftime of a podcast.
- Greg?
(mumbling) Greg?
(Greg laughing)
Greg, where are you?
- Antonio Brown has been
in the news all week.
First he got into a sideline altercation,
or just argument with his coaches.
And then on Monday, a
former Steelers PR guy
sent a Tweet out saying that Antonio Brown
needs to thank his lucky
stars because he was drafted
by a team that had Ben.
And Ben got AB paid.
And Antonio Brown quote retweeted that
and just responded, "Trade
me; let's find out."
And of course, everyone
went a little nuts.
Antonio Brown also didn't
show up to work on Monday,
which is the day they get
treatment, they have meetings.
Wasn't there; it's unclear
whether it was excused or not.
His agent says he does
not want to be traded.
But he put that out there on social media.
Trade me; let's find out.
What do you think of
your team falling apart
so early in the season?
- I mean, it's actually kind of,
I wouldn't say it's a joy.
I expect us to fully rebound
and win the Super Bowl.
But it does kind of take the pressure off
of being a fan of seeing
Le'Veon kind of hold out,
and Antonio getting upset.
And I think Antonio'd be
getting a lot more touches
if Le'Veon was out there.
So I understand his frustration.
- I mean, he was targeted
17 times in the game.
How many more times can
they throw the ball at him?
- 18, Greg.
18 and higher.
In fact, any number higher than 17.
- [Greg] 17's an extraordinary amount.
- That the answer to your question.
Oh yeah, but wide receivers are all nuts.
Remember when Jerry Rice said he wasn't
getting enough respect
after the Super Bowl
when they named him MVP?
He's like that.
And Antonio Brown can
do whatever he wants.
He cuts his hair like he's
daring you to say something.
He smiles like he's
never had anything stuck
in his teeth before.
The man runs routes like it's the only way
to get into heaven.
And if the Steelers ever
traded him over a Tweet,
I'd jump off the tallest
cliff in Los Angeles.
And right before I hit the ground,
I'd scream, "Free skydiving lessons!"
- (chuckling) Why would
that be it that you said?
- Why would what would be what?
- Why would that be what you said?
- Free skydiving lessons?
That is the funniest thing you can yell
if you jump to your death
around other people.
If you were standing there,
and someone fell to death
right in front of you,
and right before they fell, they yelled,
"Free skydiving lessons!"
You would not be able to stop laughing.
(Greg chuckling)
That is the absolute
funniest thing you could yell
jumping to your death.
- I think it would
confuse a lot of people.
- Yeah.
But in a funny way.
Erika, back me up.
- [Erika] That'd be pretty funny.
- But you would never know.
You would never know would you?
- What do you mean?
- I mean, you would never
know the reaction that it got.
- No, but it wouldn't matter.
- If it landed.
- You would know.
- You would hear about it in heaven.
(Greg chuckling)
But again if you think if anyone,
if any of the viewers or listeners
can think of something funnier to yell
when you jump to your death
than free skydiving lessons,
then please, please let me know.
But I've thought about
this a lot for years,
and I've finally gotten to use it
with this Antonio Brown story.
(rock music)